when a film's main marketing campaign
shows a group of young penguins doing
their own rendition of sexy back there
are bad things it's the wave of change
we've got to get on the ride
the first Happy Feet film I just wasn't
into I didn't get it I wasn't
entertained by it I didn't think it was
that funny so you know I'm not really
looking forward to the second film but
of course I will see it for you this was
about a young penguin he's a little cute
little boy and through a little bit of a
tectonic plate shifting and iceberg
crashes into this place where all the
Penguins live and traps them there there
are plenty of reasons to dance let's
play the only way to find out is to try
it come on son this world
Eric it wasn't that bad now we have
Elijah Wood penguin up on the hill and
we have little cute penguin and Janet
Jackson penguin I don't even know if
she's voiced by Janet Jackson or not but
she likes to sing Rhythm Nation quite a
bit so she might be she's stuck down in
the hole Robin Williams is the crazy
awesomes
like Spanish I'm guessing penguin and we
got this penguin that can apparently fly
and then we have these two little krill
under the ocean voice by Brad Pitt and
Matt Damon and these two krill are
trying to learn how to be something
other than krill they want to climb the
food chain ladder basically the themes
of this movie are people trying to break
out of their shell and do things that
their kind don't normally do or you know
things that people tell them they can't
do where are you going I want to be free
built in that way the film has a nice
message but I still wasn't very into it
just like the first I have very similar
feeling as I did to the first it's not
an awful movie at all it's just it's a
children's movie you know there's a
difference between this kind of
children's movie and a children's film
like say Toy Story that film is a film
that kids adults and teenagers will
enjoy with this film I really felt that
it was just kids you know and I think
kids will enjoy the film young kids it
didn't annoy me to know and there were
times when I rolled my eyes but for the
most part it's a kids movie you know
the entire population is trapped by huge
walls of ice and snow if you've been a
subscriber for a while you know that
sometimes I'm annoyed with singing in
movies random singing where people just
burst out and so on there are films
where it works fantastically like say
The Lion King then there are films like
this where it just feels so a place like
there's one scene where this little
penguin just bursts out in this operatic
rendition of this song where he tries to
get his father to love him or something
and it's just it just seems so out of
place and dark even I don't know I
didn't like the coyness of it the
cheesiness of it and I was not into the
main story of this penguin that could
supposedly fly and they're trapped down
there and I didn't care about it at all
we're penguins we can't fly however the
film's animation is fantastic and a 3d
is very good now the two characters in
this film that I loved and actually
adored were the two krill voiced by Brad
Pitt and Matt Damon Matt Damon I could
actually see an entire spin-off film
with just those two characters and be
perfectly happy I was into their little
story I thought it was really awesome
and it was funny too they had all the
best lines my biggest laughs and the
movie came from a line Brad Pitt had was
3d for the sequences what the curl is
actually pretty astounding my friend who
I was sitting next to actually went Wow
at one part and I was thinking the same
thing
so like I said it's not a horrible movie
I just didn't really expect much out of
it because I wasn't a fan of the first
one it's not one of the better
children's films it's not awful and I'm
gonna give Happy Feet to a C+ I'm gonna
go do you want something that has a face
a little chewy you just nibbled on its
butt if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck -
bring in fluffy
sorry